so Marvel has a new infinity stone and
it's amazing check this out so this
story takes place during the current
Thor run and we'll have a link to the
playlist of the Thor videos down in the
comments section so you can go check it
out but what it does here is it
initially picks up with Thanos basically
during the age of born now what's cool
about this is it says it took him years
to discover where he was years of living
in this harsh beautiful and brutal World
in this wild time but now he knows this
is the world this is the age of bored so
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with the Thor Mythos Bohr is the
grandfather of Thor and the father of
Odin during this point in time life was
exceedingly harsh now this is in the
ancient history of Marvel Comics and the
question has to be asked how did Thanos
get here so the way this works and it's
kind of hinted too but I'll explain it
here in a second we're literally told he
remembers life before before his life
and his death he remembers losing sight
of hella as they fell through time and
space and the agony of the black hole
but that was many years ago now ancient
past or dis instant future depending on
how you view it knowing it is coming he
has waited patiently for this day
tonight war will create something that
will change the universe and Thanos
would not miss it for the world so the
thing to understand here is that during
Donnie Kate's run on Guardians of the
Galaxy Thanos was ultimately defeated
and dropped into a gravity wealth now
Marvel Comics plays Gravity Wells fast
and loose right black holes they play it
fast and loose sometimes black holes or
just gravity Wells with no defined
bottom right it just kind of seemingly
stretches on to Forever and this story
what Marvel does or at least in
Guardians of the Galaxy what they did is
they treated the black hole as a
temporal Vortex a portal through space
and time and so what happened is when
Thanos fell through the gravity well he
was sent back to the days of ancient
Asgard and the days of boar now the
reason why I say this place is so harsh
is because back in the time of boar gods
were stronger they were more capable
they were brutal right it's like Star
Wars right you have like Anakin
Skywalker and you've got you know
Emperor Palpatine and so on but they
pale in comparison to like the ancient
Sith Lords like exarcoon and just the
sheer amount of power that they had
that's kind of what you're looking at
here when it comes to that comparison
with Marvel it was a very dark harsh and
brutal time now lest we forget one of
the things that was given to us in the
Run of Thor is that somewhere along the
line Bohr had basically harnessed the
ability to create an infinity stone
Thanos had just seemingly arrived on the
scene a bit of a battle ensued but we
never actually found out what happened
next all we knew was that there seemed
to have been the creation of a seventh
Stone and it was housed in the Vault of
boar when Thor went to try to find it
there was no possible way he could
locate it right that was covered in the
Thanos Death Note storyline it was
really really cool but it was a really
awesome bit of History here but what we
end up doing is transitioning to boar
along with his Sorcerers while he's in
the midst of trying to create this
seventh Stone and what they do is they
show him Thanos and we end up finding
out boar is aware of the fact that
Thanos has been here the entire time now
one of the cool things about this and
this is something that I want to
illustrate Boar's not concerned about
Thanos now this creates a a really
compelling argument because something
that we've never seen in the history of
Marvel Comics is a fight between Thanos
and bore and we honestly don't exactly
know who would win if I'm a betting man
I would put my money on board right I
think boar would actually come out on
top in a fight between the two but given
the conflict that we also saw with these
characters in the Thor run specifically
in death notes it looks like Thanos
might win so I want to know from you
guys down in the comments section if the
father of Odin and Thanos were to fight
who would actually kill the other who
would win right I want to know your
all's thoughts down there in the
comments section but the important thing
here is this right with boar realizing
that Thanos is here and with his
Sorcerers basically telling him thanos's
time displace and even giving him a bit
of history on Thanos and saying he's
here for the seventh stone that
basically tells Bohr that the entire
experiment goes off without a hitch they
successfully create the artifact which
really kind of points to the idea that
there was a bit of hesitation on behalf
of Borg as to whether or not it would
actually work but the real kicker to
This Is How They even create the stone
in the first place because as you guys
know with the Infinity Stones in Marvel
Comics they came into existence with the
birth of the universe now technically
speaking if you do want to invoke
Nemesis and the old ultraverse stuff I
think it was ultraverse back in the day
the Marvel ultraverse crossover that the
Infinity Stones originated with a being
called Nemesis and that Nemesis
basically sick from loneliness destroyed
itself and Scattered its Essence across
the entirety of the cosmos which gave us
the Infinity Stones and seemingly
everything in existence after that
Nemesis took off and that's when you
actually find a seventh infinity stone
that's not really in continuity anymore
right this kind of does away with all of
that stuff but it's a little bit of a
cool history there if you want to invoke
that but the important thing here is
that the Infinity Stones came into
existence seemingly with the birth of
the universe and so they are a part and
parcel to existence itself they were not
artificially created by someone so it
creates a really interesting scenario
when you kind of find yourself in this
situation of somebody artificially
creating a stone because when the
question has to be asked how do you make
a stone that can presumably tap into the
powers of the universe it's not easily
done and so what happens is we're told
the heavy pieces of shell that once held
the galactose seed do not burn easily
Vore Sorcerers thought the natural heat
of niflheim's core would be enough they
were wrong so they have brought the
Eternal Flame of mossful from the depths
of muscle hunt rumors have it that you
can see the future in the blazing fire
but no one has ever come close enough to
find out if this is true what we're
being told here is the core of the
ability to create the stone is housed
with the Galactus seed itself and that
makes perfect sense so for those of you
guys who are familiar with the Galactus
seed it's really really cool the idea
behind this is that before the current
Universe came into existence the cosmic
entity eternity created the Galactus
seed which is where the new universe
will be born from so if we want to take
this as an absolute truth and I'll tell
you why we can't necessarily do that
here in a second then we could look at
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four run
and the conversation between Galactus
and Franklin Richards who were equal in
power and when Galactus tells Franklin
that when the universe basically dies
the two of them will stand as its last
survivors and be reborn Anew into the
new universe that presumably they would
meet the Galactus seat and the Galactus
seed would quite literally absorb and
pull everything into itself and then
explode outward with a big bang creating
a Galactus Franklin Richards merger as a
new cosmic entity along with whatever
other Cosmic entities in life come out
of it now the reason why we can't take
that as an absolute truth is because
with the Galactus seed one of the things
we also know is that Bohr eventually
discovered it and when he did he created
the universe as We Know It This runs
into direct conflict with the nature of
like the celestials that the celestials
were the beings who created everything
in existence following their war with
the first firmament the birth of the
Multiverse and so on and so forth and
there's ample other explanations right
in Marvel comics on how the universe
came into existence the builders from
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers the new Wally who were created
by the beyonders it's just one of these
things where the galactic seed is just
yet another example of how Marvel tries
to explain the universe coming into
resistance so again you can't take it as
an absolute truth the important thing
here though is that with the
implementation of the fire of musculheim
literally these Flames that are on a
whole other level of power combined with
the Galactus seed as we know from the
Death Note story it led to the eruption
of the mountain and the deaths of an
astronomical number of Boar's forces but
what ended up happening is that with
Thanos surviving the entire ordeal
Thanos enters into the cave and finds
the priestesses in the midst of forming
this infinity stone and the entire
process is already completed the problem
with this is that when Thanos gets there
to where the stones at he ends up
finding out that it's a child and what
we're told here is that his questions
echo through the mountain but there is
no answer only silence and death so
here's the question that I have because
this is what fans are debating across
the internet right now who were fans of
the Thor Mythos and are reading this
story the question people are asking is
is this a literal interpretation or is
it a metaphor equal interpretation
there's no doubting this is a little
girl a child born as the seventh
infinity stone the seventh stone is not
just some object that exists out there
it's a living being so is it hella is it
mistress death we don't entirely know
because hella is actually the daughter
of Loki right so it's a little murky to
suddenly come across and change her
history to make her fit here it's
possible you could argue it's mistress
death but mistress death has been around
since the beginnings of the universe she
wasn't born at some arbitrary point in
time she's always been there so we don't
exactly know who this is so I want to
know your thoughts on this right do you
think it's somebody that we've never
seen before do you think it's hella do
you think it's mistress death or do you
think it's someone that we have seen we
just don't know that it's them let me
know down in the comments section but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]